depuis deux ans Lucille une jeune femme
d'une vingtaine d'années est harcelée et
menacée sur les réseaux sociaux par un
inconnu je vais tout faire pour te
retrouver d'accord donc fais pas je te
le conseille et hier soir lucide était
sur notre plateau pour crier son
désarroi et lancer un appel à l'aide
j'ai l'impression d'être tout le temps
en cabane alors que c'est pas à moi de
fuir c'est pas à moi de changer de pays
un témoignage effroyable qui a
bouleversé de nombreux téléspectateurs
j'ai envie de vomir le système
judiciaire refuse de protéger les femmes
et laisse les agresseurs sévirent dans
l'impunité et selon certains son
agresseur qui le fait vivre un enfer
aurait un profil un peu particulier dans
le dossier on parle du fait que cette
personne soit protégée alors qui est
donc cet homme qu'il a harcèle lucide
poursuivit par harceleur en liberté les
révélations de Michel Marie sur le
suspect ce soir dans TPMP merci Michel
et Marie d'être avec nous vous êtes là
pour nous en dire un peu plus sur le
profil du harceleur de Lucille parce que
depuis hier j'ai plein plein de messages
de gens qui me disent bah ça peut
m'arriver à moi aussi si je réponds si
je fais un truc donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez troublant lucide est une
jeune de 20 ans depuis deux ans elle
vient d'enfer un homme la harcèle la
suit la menace et son prend assez proche
en fait ça a démarré il a commencé un
peu à lui parler à la un peu l'attaquer
un peu sur les réseaux et lui a répondu
en message privé et derrière ça a été un
déferlement et un acharnement alors
malgré ces nombreux appels à l'aide
l'homme est actuellement liberté il a
fait plusieurs séjours en prison mais il
n'a jamais fait la totalité de sa peine
malgré les récidives elle a été obligée
de déménager plusieurs fois aujourd'hui
elle en est un stade où elle n'ose même
plus partir tellement elle a peur pour
sa famille à se Dissy s'attaque pas à
moi il va s'attaquer à ma famille Michel
Marie qui est cet homme
c'est un garçon de 23 ans maintenant
qui n'est pas débordé par l'activité
professionnelle dans d'autres termes il
n'a jamais rien fait
il dit en famille dans le Val-d'Oise et
il passe beaucoup de temps a priori sur
les réseaux sociaux et là
a priori il fait pas grand chose à part
harceler en tout cas un certain nombre
de filles parce que Lucile n'est pas la
seule victime de ce garçon il y en a eu
d'autres d'ailleurs avant l'affaire qui
concerne Lucile dont on va reparler il a
été condamné à trois reprises sans
casier judiciaire mentionne 3
condamnation pour quel motif alors la
première c'est quand il était mineur
mais a priori ça a l'air de coller avec
une affaire où il serait rentré dans un
lycée pour tenter de kidnapper son ex
petit ami celle qui l'avait quitté on
doit être en 2014 ou 2016 donc il est
très jeune il est mineur et les autres
affaires semblent être du même du même
acabit ce type est obsessionnel je pense
que le problème est plus psychologique
voire psychiatrique que judiciaire enfin
il est les deux d'ailleurs et là en fait
on traite rien et je pense d'ailleurs je
lance un peu un cri d'alarme parce que
tous les signaux sont en rouge pour
qu'il arrive un drame vraiment ce mec
n'a pas frein cette semaine n'a pas de
frein il est en prison il est pas sorti
de prison qu'il a déjà le projet de tuer
Lucile il le dit au téléphone un de ses
amis la conversation est écoutée
elle est rapportée évidemment
c'est quand même un drôle de
comportement quand on est incarcéré pour
des faits graves de menaces de mort on
peut imaginer que quelques mois derrière
les barreaux vont vous calmer lui
apparemment ça le calme pas puisqu'il y
a avant même de sortir il a déjà le
projet de commettre un crime donc je
pense honnêtement que alors moi j'ai une
question qui est vraiment peut-être
complètement con moi quand on alors bien
sûr il y a des peines qu'on fait on
prend par exemple deux ans voilà parce
qu'on a harcelé quelqu'un donc lui il a
fait il a fait combien de mois je crois
une première fois et trois mois alors il
y a fait 11 mois ouais c'est bien sûr
mais à un moment quand il y a un mec
comme ça qui dit en prison quand je vais
sortir je vais tuer la personne que j'ai
harcelé même si ça peine elle est de 8
mois un moment on va se dire bon on va
quand même le garder ici lui non le
principe est en prison c'est parce que
parfois on peut représenter un danger
pour les autres et pour la société là
typiquement le mec j'ai plein de moi
j'ai plein de un pote en prison et je le
dis au placard et qui me regarde alors
j'en fais de gros bisous qui
représentent beaucoup moins un danger
pour la société qu'un gars comme ça et
qui sont au placard donc il y a un
moment il y a pas aussi un problème tu
as pas un problème avec la justice toi
en prison oui il y a un problème
maintenant il y a également
les règles de droit là en l'occurrence
cette affaire n'a pas il y a pas eu de
suite judiciaire à cette affaire parce
qu'il s'est défendu il a été entendu sur
ce point il a dit mélange ça pour
déconner
j'étais pas sérieux j'étais en colère
j'avais mes nerfs ont craqué etc et
comme mec il a des antécédents à un
moment tu vas croire alors on va croire
on va pas croire des gars je vous le dis
j'ai des potes moi qui sont retournés au
placard je vous jure que c'est vrai pour
des simples rendez-vous moi j'ai un pote
je vous dis à vérité il a fait 18 ans de
placard
il y a un copain à lui qui s'est fait un
petit peu emmerder par des gars il a
juste fait un rendez-vous pour dire on
calme l'histoire ils l'ont mis direct au
placard
très bonne amie à moi qui est
actuellement et je peux vous dire que ça
voilà donc à lui et il représentait plus
un danger pour la société je vous le dis
il était vraiment rangé et il voulait
juste vivre une vie normale donc et lui
il est retourné au placard donc là un
gars comme ça truc lui il est dehors
c'est alors l'autre aspect de ce dossier
c'est que c'est pas en prise directe
c'est-à-dire que si je vous dis vous
Cyril je vais vous tuer c'est une menace
de mort si je dis à Gilles Verdez Cyril
Hanouna je vais le tuer c'est pas à vous
que je parle c'est à lui et on peut
considérer
donc là non non c'est vraiment attaquant
directe si vous voulez et je mettrais
bien m'en défendre en disant mais non
j'ai dit ça pour rire j'adore Cyril
Hanouna et tout va bien donc voilà et
puis après il y a un contexte il faut
que j'ai une raison de vous en vouloir
non mais oui mais lui et donc je vous
dis franchement si fou cette affaire oui
en plus là les preuves elles sont là en
plus si la franchi la barrière du
virtuelle parce qu'il s'est pointé chez
elle il y a beaucoup de menaces qui
restent virtuelle là il est venu chez
elle bien sûr après chez elle il y a un
problème en France et c'est triste à
dire mais malheureusement tant qu'il
n'arrive pas à un drame c'est à dire une
agression extrêmement grave un viol ou
pyramer on voulait la justice oui moi
aussi on ne prend pas les menaces au
sérieux et ça les harceleur le savent
lui-même il dit dans ses notes vocale de
toute façon je sais que j'irai pas 20
ans au placard et même les gens qui
voient ça se disent aujourd'hui bah moi
je peux menacer de moi n'importe qui il
ne m'arrivera rien et c'est terrible ces
mecs là ils doivent rester au moins 10
ans 20 ans c'est extrêmement grave ce
qu'il fait mais qu'il avait qu'un
couteau il se filme on a toutes les
preuves qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
attend
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
réponde non mais cet endroit l'intention
de vos pas forcément l'action
est fort heureusement d'ailleurs tu veux
faire ça moi je pense vraiment que la
réponse dans cette histoire est je pense
qu'il faut vraiment que les gens se
bougent enfin le service les services
compétences bougent il y a une solution
c'est de c'est de le faire expertiser
psychiatrique une expertise cicatrique
et l'internet d'office ce type est fou
ce type est complètement dingue pour
vous alors moi je préfère j'aimerais
qu'on parle moi juste sa famille parce
que il y a Lucile qui me disait hier que
son père est policier ou gendarme et son
oncle aussi
oui alors j'ai essayé des informations
que j'ai pas pu
recouper on me l'a dit on me l'a dit
aussi
mais moi j'ai pour habitude quand même
d'essayer de recouper au mois de fois
mes infos avant de
rassurera peut-être la chaîne que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure c'est pas comme
Thierry donc
on m'a dit effectivement que son père
avait un poste important dans la police
maintenant je pense qu'il faut aussi
calmer un peu les fantasmes de la
protection aujourd'hui on l'a vu pour
Dupont-Moretti on l'a vu pour un certain
nombre de gens importants on ne peut
plus rien arranger c'était facile dans
les années 80-90 un coup de fil tout
s'arrangeait ou alors pour des choses
pas importantes mais là pour une affaire
comme ça je vois pas quel magistrat va
abandonner les poursuites contre cet
individu au prétexte que le père est
commissaire de police et qu'il a passé
un coup de fil sauf que Michel alors il
y a peut-être pas de protection directe
mais il y a quand même chez ce harceleur
une connaissance parfaite de tout le
système c'est ça aussi qui confirme que
la fausse selon laquelle on me l'a dit
je suis comme vous c'est-à-dire qu'on
n'a pas pu le confirmer mais on nous l'a
dit et dans le dans le dossier on n'a
pas trouvé les termes qui le stipule
mais avec Michel on a enquêté
effectivement on nous répète ça alors
s'il y a pas de protection directe il y
a quand même chez lui une connaissance
parfaite de tous les procédures ce qui
crée les possibilités d'un entourage
très au fait de tout ça il a des
obligations de soin il respecte pas il
doit plus entrer en contact il respecte
pas obligation de trouver un travail
jamais à chaque fois dans la procédure
quand on l'ennuie trop lui porte plainte
donc la justice est face à deux plaintes
et donc la justice est un peu perdue il
est extrêmement malin donc payé par un
avocat peut-être aussi oui ou bien ou
bien conseiller c'est une hypothèse par
des membres de sa famille qui savent
comment alors jouer louvoyer entre les
procédures Lucie me disait hier Lucie
elle me dit que quand elle part elle
vient donc faire plus simple à mon
commissariat sa famille est directement
au courant il lui dise et il lui dit tu
as porté tu vas voir ça tu vas voir ce
qui va t'arriver si le père est dans la
police effectivement par le biais des
fichiers on arrive à savoir par le Tage
notamment
à chaque fois qu'il y a une place
enregistrée le tâches
je me rappelle plus du reste des
infractions en temps réel ou pas comme
ça d'accord non c'est pas ça du tout
d'ailleurs mais c'est bon en bref vous
avez déposé plainte au commissariat une
fois que vous avez terminé de déposer
votre plainte vous êtes inscrits sur un
fichier comme quoi vous êtes auteur ou
victime d'un crime ou d'un délit
d'accord vous êtes impliqués dans une
directement cette chanson si on le sait
direct par le donc voilà si un policier
fait des vérifications via l'ordinateur
favial les fichiers
alors un jeune homme qui s'embête
totalement obsédé par Lucile regardez ce
qu'il envoie
faut que tu saches un truc là en juillet
rien qu'en juillet j'étais condamné à de
la prison ferme mais regarde où je suis
je suis libre comme l'air je fais ce que
je veux il y a toujours un moyen moi je
veux toujours me démerder sauf que la
même si j'arrive je te vois je t'égorge
de viole je sais que je prendrai jamais
j'en ai rien à [__] je m'en bats les
couilles moi là tout ce que je veux
c'est ton gros tu as compris ça je vais
rester poli
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il a avec Lucile qu'est-ce
qui il est amoureux il y a le procureur
là à l'occasion d'un procès à Pontoise
qui a requis contre lui deux ans de
prison là où il a pris 8 mois et
il dit quand même que il a des troubles
de la personnalité un comportement
dangereux il harcèle il menace il
poursuivra Lucile aussi longtemps qu'il
l'aura dans la peau ah d'accord mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a il a dit quoi au
procureur quand il a été entendu il a
dit quoi il a dit voilà c'est quoi ce
sont français d'accord il a dit quoi
d'autre
j'étais pas au procès je sais pas ce
qu'il a dit exactement mais en tout cas
il a il a dû bien se défendre où il a
été bien défendu puisqu'effectivement il
a pris une peine sur deux ans requis il
est condamné à moi la question que il
continue comment se fait-il qu'il soit
dehors encore alors ça c'est une donnée
une vraie question
logiquement à partir du moment où il est
sous contrôle judiciaire qu'il a
l'interdiction de de voir
logiquement avec ce qu'il a fait le
week-end dernier c'est à dire de tenter
de s'introduire à son domicile et de
prendre la fuite ensuite il devrait être
immédiatement incarcéré donc je ne sais
pas pourquoi il ne l'est pas alors je
sais par par j'ai eu une avocate dans
cette histoire je sais qu'il j'ai perdu
le fil oui qui a des ils sont en appel
donc est-ce que l'appel est suspensive
de c'est possible mais j'ai pas ça a été
très vite si vous voulez j'ai pas eu
j'ai pas eu le temps nécessaire pour
vous ramener cette information Michel là
on peut se demander si la justice
protège suffisamment les victimes c'est
que il a retrouvé la trace de ses
parents grâce à la plainte déposée du
coup il y avait l'adresse de ses parents
sur le le procès le procès-verbal et du
coup il s'est rendu immédiatement chez
les parents la justice devrait protéger
quand même victime c'est quand même
délirant il a retrouvé leur trace gras
avec la justice
il y a toujours un moyen je vais me
démerder ça rejoint ce que ce que dit
Jean-Michel c'est à dire que il a une
connaissance parfaite il sait comment
jouer de tout ça et il n'arrête pas de
de faire ça et effectivement moi je
pense que comme il avait une peine de 8
mois il en a fait trois je comprends pas
là c'est inadmissible qui soit pas
immédiatement remis au trou pour les
cinq mois restants c'est impossible là
souvent je défends la justice mais là il
y a un vrai problème c'est impossible
que la justice n'agisse par là un
bracelet bon on sache où il est il
puisse pas s'approcher à domicile du
domicile il est vraiment dans la toute
puissance c'est-à-dire que il se sent
totalement invincible il le dit
d'ailleurs il dit moi il m'arrive rien
je peux te violer je peux te égorger
je ferais même pas 20 ans donc ils s'en
fout complètement mais une fois de plus
je pense qu'il a un problème
psychiatrique et que le préfet de du Val
d'Oise peut le faire interner si on a un
psychiatre qui dit qu'il faut le faire
Lucie l'a dit hier qu'il avait porté
plainte lui aussi le contraire il a
porté plainte pourquoi il estime qu'il
est victime de quoi lui en fait alors en
fait ce qui apparaît dans le dossier je
mets du conditionnel c'est que à un
moment des gens auraient retrouver il y
a en 2021 des gens auraient retrouvé son
adresse et aurait monté 100 100 Lucille
soit au courant sans du tout hein je la
dédouane totalement aurait monté une
sorte de de petite équipe pour aller
là-bas et pour lui dire calme-toi
prendre des photos etc et ce qui se dit
aussi j'en peux encore inconditionnel
c'est qu'à ce moment-là les parents
sortaient du domicile qui aurait eu un
petit heure qu'ils auraient failli être
renversé et que aurait porté plainte à
ce moment-là voilà donc la famille s'est
soudée et de ce que je sais la famille
ne prend aucun recul avec lui et la
famille fait bloque avec lui voilà je
mets du conditionnel quand même est-ce
que la médiatisation de reste à faire à
la télévision ça peut accélérer le
processus judiciaire oui j'espère parce
que aujourd'hui tous ceux qui sont
concernés sur un plan judiciaire
ne prie le ciel qui n'arrive rien à
lucide si
malheur il lui arrivait quelque chose
tous ceux qui ont le pouvoir de
neutraliser cet individu et qui ne l'ont
pas fait
auront des comptes à rendre donc là tout
le monde le sait on peut pas dire ah bah
tiens on découvre un dossier non là ça
fait deux jours qu'on parle de cette
histoire
vous avez vu déjà dans des femmes des
féminicides par exemple des gens qui ont
des comptes à rendre la justice on les
voit jamais on les entend jamais on les
connaît pas longtemps le policier de
Blois cette femme qui a été battue à
mort qui appelle la police au secours et
ce policier qui lui écoutait
rappelez-moi demain le lendemain elle
était morte le policier je peux vous
dire qu'il était un policier alors il y
a Lucile s'il vous plaît il y a Lucile
on lui avait demandé on lui a demandé un
sur Twitter la police ne t'a pas
contacté comme ils ont dit dans leur
tweet si mais il est toujours dehors
apparemment voilà c'est un tweet de
Lucie il a il y a une heure donc voilà
donc là il est toujours dehors et
forcément la vie de Lucile c'est c'est
un enfer merci Michel Marie d'avoir été
avec nous toujours très clair et
toujours un bonheur de vous voir avec
des vrais infos ça change des autres
chaînes allez on va